speaker dropped out last minute
both of our backup speakers not here
so
Molly who gave a Spoke spot talked to us
a minute ago
got one of her team members to come
straight from the office
so with no slides please welcome Thomas
thank you uh well very excited to be
here everyone my name is Thomas Backus
like uh
like I was mentioned I work with Molly
I'm the assistant team lead of our data
and surveys analytics group or Bloomberg
law so I'm going to speak generally
about uh actually my my previous world
before joining Bloomberg law where I was
a data scientist with Maguire Woods LLP
our offices in DC I like the joke that
it made my commute especially bad
because it's right next to the White
House so uh pretty much any news that
came out would add 10 15 minutes to my
commute in but I gave a previous talk a
few months ago at the ilta convention
which is really unfortunate the the
title of that talk was what is a data
scientist and how you use them at your
firm and I'm working under the
assumption that many of you guys know
the answer to that first question so
um an important aspect of that that
event was really talking about
leveraging data science and a an
industry that otherwise wouldn't be as
especially technical so in that case it
was legal legal's always been a slow
adopter to Tech generally there's
apprehension to engaging new
technologies in legal and myself and the
other panelists were talking about how
we found great success engaging
non-technical people with data science
tools so a few of the techniques that we
used in that process was one we we
wanted to always work as strategic
advisors and as opposed to working and
using the sort of data science mindset
to address problems where everything's
very technical mathematics statistics
based we tried to deconstruct problems
with the context of a non-technical user
in mind so one of the great tools that
we use for that was visualization and
that's sort of the great middle ground
when you're trying to bridge the gap
between technical results and sort of
easily digestible results so um
I mentioned the general apprehension
with legal when we came in uh so the the
group that I helped co-found was called
McGuire Woods Excel and essentially we
were providing at that time was data
science Consulting with our litigation
teams and our in-house Enterprise teams
so we worked in two different segments
so my specialization is working directly
with our litigators in courtrooms trying
to find ways that we could use data to
improve the outcomes of our attorney
work so that manifested in a lot of
different ways
um
primarily we tried to use data to set a
ground objective truth so some of the
cases that we worked on
were large defense cases of insider
trading or using Healthcare data
defending doctors and as opposed to
making General claims without having a
solid statistical basis we leveraged our
expertise using big data resources so
this could be like trade data this could
be population data or Healthcare data to
set that objective ground truth that was
one of the great ways that we were able
to find that we weren't replacing the
work that our attorneys were doing
because otherwise we'd be out of the job
because they wouldn't want us involved
in their practice
but more so working in that strategic
mindset of providing insight and
informing decisions that were already
being made so along the way
[Music]
we built a series of tools and and this
isn't our conference I generally use
Python but we did use r as well so ready
your Tomatoes if that's the the topic
um but you know we we we built
visualization tools into some of the
Integrations that we had in mind so uh
risk is a big aspect of the legal
proceedings and calculating risk is an
important part of the work that we do so
uh when we were building risk
calculators for industry groups we tried
to build in simplified visualization at
every step of the way so you could
monitor how changes to Any Given risk
calculation would impact the results as
you were as you were doing it so the
sensitivity analysis was being performed
by the attorneys as they were using the
tool I really wish
this is going to be another out or short
notice that I had some
slides to show you because they would
illustrate that much better but use your
imaginations that there's a very cool
um
like web app that exists on on the
screen here
um but yeah so besides that uh we we
wanted to also turn our Focus to the
business unit of the law firm because uh
I don't know what Molly necessarily
talked about but our familiarity with
law firms is that they're trending more
toward running more efficiently as a
business and for all the data scientists
in here it's a great opportunity for you
to look out as opposed to working just
solely in Tech Fields trying to engage
data science as a business practice as
well where using business intelligence
and the insights that you can gather to
really inform the practice of your of
your business or law firm in this case
so one of the one of the questions that
we gotten for any of the practicing data
scientists here you probably get
something at at where you work where
it's like we have problem X so in our
case it was we have associate it's
turning over at X Y rate and our ogc our
office of general counsel was asking the
question of like why does that happen so
I came up with this extensive
quantitative solution calculate turnover
and they sort of turned their nose up at
that immediately but one of the other
data scientists on the team built a
network diagram which basically had our
Associates connected to our partners and
the edge nodes were the matters that
they were involved in and what we found
in that visualization was that all of
the edge cases of our Associates ended
up turning over and the sort of
qualitative inference that we got from
that was that the associates that aren't
involved in as many matters with more
Partners turn over at a much higher rate
than those that don't and using that
information the ogc was able to inform
decisions moving forward of like pulling
not only similar Associates under new
matters but also Partners into
underutilized Associates and all that
was created we again I'm going to keep
defaulting to python tools we we used
power bi and Django but all that could
have been done with r and r shiny so
it's it's one of those great
um
sort of intuitive business case results
that that that was really really fun to
work on
um
yeah so outside of that
um
one one thing that I wish I had known
joining what I'll call a sort of
underutilized industry was uh the
difficulty of of adoption uh and this is
this is something that comes up quite a
bit if you are working in a business
that otherwise doesn't use data at their
at their core now we're finding more and
more that business regardless of their
focus on data are collecting it and you
really need to become The Advocate and
uh the expert in driving the adoption
wherever you were
when we founded mwxl at McGuire Woods we
started to engage in teams that weren't
actually working with us already we just
had access to their data and we're
trying to build solutions to problems
that we knew existed in them even before
we got asked so really we were trying to
build a
minimal viable product for them
and provide that offer alongside the
business they already created and I
think that as especially in the legal
industry the maturity of Technology
continues to happen
data scientists especially need to be
working as the focus to drive adoption
and continue to be advocates for
engaging technology wherever you work so
yeah
what's my time am I good
okay
well I can keep talking uh
unfortunately again I'm gonna I'm gonna
turn to my notes and
I I looked at these on the car right
over and I was like hmm
data science what does a data scientist
mix up about
85 percent of this so uh yeah uh so I'm
going to point to a couple quotes that
are really
relevant to what I had mentioned before
which is that
uh data analysis with lawyers pace so
this is a quote from David Burnett in
his article entitled the importance of
data and data analysis and litigation in
law 360. and in that he says data
analysis allows lawyers to bridge the
gap from Individual to Collective proof
lawyers can use investment Market data
sales records public health records
demographic data and the like to
generate compelling claims and evidence
about incredibly broad subjects in short
Big Data allows for a big litigation so
um sort of what I mentioned before
trying to visualize that in practice is
if
you want to make I'm going to point to
an example that we had pulled up with
one of our litigation teams so
um we had an employment employee lawsuit
uh defense case and the the company that
we were representing is basically making
the claim like there's no way that this
event could occur on random chance
um
twice in this time frame and for do we
have any lawyers in here by the way
before I make disparaging remarks on on
lawyers
no okay excellent so um lawyers aren't
especially good at statistics and
generally they don't go into the
practice of law to learn math and and
I'm sort of looking over at Molly to see
if there's going to be any like you know
are we we're losing business okay
um
okay good
excellent yeah so
um we really wanted to try to prove out
this conditional probability case which
uh
this is more of a statistics thing than
it is in our thing so I'm diverging so
forgive me but
um we we we're trying to calculate this
probability of occurring so we had this
one event that occurred at XYZ time
frame that was especially odd which
theoretically in a vacuum could have
occurred by random chance but the fact
that it occurred two and three times
after that at the same rate which was
the case of I think it was an injury uh
seemed a bit fishy and essentially what
it came down to with our little with the
litigators on this case we ended up
getting dismissed was that there was a
unnatural precedent for these occurrence
occurrences to happen within a
reasonable time frame and essentially
how we presented that was for one case
to occur it's one in a million chance
for this case to occur twice it's one in
10 million and for one in this case to
occur three times in a row in this time
frame it's
um one in like a billion or something
and and this is another one of those
cases where they probably could have
gotten their way around that without
understanding but working as the data
expert and the statistics expert on the
team we were able to really drive that
as an efficient efficient story and
narrative that we were building then
also along the way we were working on a
sort of brother versus brother lawsuit
over shares of the family company one
was trying to buy out the other uh the
one being bought out was saying that his
shares were worth five 10x what he had
initially valued and
we didn't really have a plan well the
litigation team didn't really have a
plan on how they wanted to manage this
this sort of collection of ownership so
we built this really extensive pipeline
that was built partially in R so we you
know good job everyone here parsley and
python sort of built that into our AWS
Network we were able to build out this
this really extensive and again these
are very hard to visualize so
imagination hats on uh dashboard and
visualization tool set that allowed in
our court proceedings uh one our client
to be able to review ownership details
of hundreds and hundreds of family-owned
properties that were related to business
but also we were able to go back to the
Auditors that had been involved in this
case that had valued all of these
properties 10 5-10x what had initially
been uh audited and we were able to show
again going toward that that data at the
core of ground uh centralized truth that
what the opinion of the auditor had made
was not necessarily reflective in the
data and so in our in our ability to
visualize that and build out that tool
set uh we we were able to sell that
narrative with which with much stronger
efficacy so
um
yes that's one more
and
how am I doing on time good
got six minutes
I kind of wish I could do questions can
I answer one question or no
yes and
sure
yeah
absolutely
foreign
yes absolutely
uh so the question was talking about
wins with adoption trying to sort of uh
illustrate what it would look like
because everybody runs into challenges
of adoption for non-technical people so
the big thing that I would focus on
always is trying to build trust and that
starts with the really easy low-hanging
fruit work that you do so uh I am guilty
of this also my data science brain is
always looking to build a really complex
solution to problems that could really
easily be solved with something simple
uh and and you really have to stop
yourself on that conclusion because what
you'll find is as you try to build these
fun complex Solutions people will turn
their nose up at that because they don't
understand it but if you build like a
simple dashboard or a visualization and
get your foot in the door that's a
really great path to adoption and and
using that as your your trust building
process and and once you start to have
that trust that whatever organization
that you're at it's way easier for you
to engage with with teams or individuals
that otherwise are not familiar with
your process but the the data process
can be scary to people that don't
understand it so my focus always is try
to build trust at the at the start do
easy things do the not fun stuff do the
things that are not complex uh and and
use that as a building block toward
building more fun projects uh again
really wish I had my slide deck but at
my previous talk I had this this uh
value complexity Matrix which basically
like uh value complexity x y and we have
those broken out into steps and it's
basically descriptive and
[Music]
um
I again I got to look at my notes but
it's it's basically descriptive and uh
at the very top we have our prescriptive
and our Predictive Analytics so we start
with the simple stuff which is low value
and low complexity we use that to
progress to our higher complexity and
higher value work
um so yeah I hope that was helpful well
it's a pleasure to be here for everyone
and uh thanks for the time